qu'ils appauvrissent l'Afrique ils pient
les os du Sénégal les bateaux étrangers
surtout russes et chinois qui dévastent
tout sur leur passage jusqu'à 6000
tonnes de poissons pêchés chaque jour
300 millions de dollars de perte par an
pour le Sénégal et avec ça des milliers
d'emplois c'est tout cela que raconte
razzia sur l'Atlantique de Nicolas
vaningen un pillage qui dure depuis des
décennies et qui est en train de créer
des situations explosives les autorités
sénégalaises ne faisant pas grand chose
les pêcheurs se rebellent parfois dans
la violence mais il arrive que cela
tourne très très mal il arrive qu'il
tombe sur plus fort que notamment face
aux Chinois
les conséquences de cette surpêche
étrangère dans les eaux africaines elle
se situe à plein de niveaux humaine et
économiques on l'a vu les écologiques
aussi puisque c'est toute une faune
marine qui est en train de disparaître
et enfin démographique l'équation est
simple plus de poissons plus de pêche
plus de travail et ce sont des milliers
de jeunes sénégalais qui fuient le pays
pour trouver un avenir meilleur en
Europe razza sur l'Atlantique une
enquête choc à voir sur Public Sénat ce
samedi à 21h je vous retrouverai juste
après pour un débat avec nos invités